hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to
minecraft i don't know why that was so
dramatic
so we've got cows and we've got a farm
and eventually i'll need to kill these
cows to get their leather
but for now i'm gonna let my plants grow
a little bit hey that's growing pretty
good
i know i could let them grow a little
more but i want to plant more
so that even more can grow at the same
time so i really don't want to be
lacking for paper anytime
soon 23 not bad 0.
okay that'll be good then that can grow
up and that should be more than enough
to
satiate my lust for
paper so what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to let them grow up i'm going to
let
them grow up and then i'm going to grow
up myself inside my soul
by going into this ravine i don't have
anything that i need yet my inventory is
full it would be a terrible idea to do
that
so i'm not going to do that what if my
house went all the way down to the
bedrock listen is that a genius idea or
what
no why not why is that bad give me one
good reason
give me 15 good reasons
i thought not i'ma do it i'm going to
dig
down to the bedrock right here because i
don't want to have to go all the way up
and down to be able to do whatever yada
yada
something something excuses uh reasons
you know just pretend like i'm giving
good reasons i don't need that
i don't need that i need more ladders
okay ladders
time to go up to my crafting room
[Laughter]
this is awfully inconvenient bam
30 is not really enough
i need more wood before i go down no i
don't
this time i'm going to dig two holes at
once because i'm smart
bedrock i've done it i always knew i
could
time to go back up no
no
please tell me i have enough of these
please tell me i have enough
because if i don't have enough i'm gonna
have a big problem
cat cat save me i need your assistance
cat please meow twice if you know where
i am
hello well that's a stupid hole in my
well i mean there i guess there's a
stupid hole there too but
i can fix that with a door i knew i knew
there was a reason that these doors came
in threes
just gotta put it in there put it in
there
okay well that's not working i'm gonna
go to bed and think on this
my door's open
you can't get in silly spider
itsy bitsy spider getting chopped up all
about
that didn't really go well but i killed
you nonetheless and i'm alive and you're
dead
i gotta go get more wood that's a lot of
creepers here
oh you light on fire when i hit you
that's
epic yo that's epic
and now with that we shall continue our
mine
okay and with that i will get water so
that i can make a drop
zone we
saved it all right now let's make it uh
right right here yeah that seems good
okay and this will be the landing zone
so that i can start my new mine this is
high enough for diamonds right
maybe it's a little too high i think
it's like 12 blocks one
two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven
i mean if it's twelve if it's time
twelve then i'm just being kind of an
idiot but
no one ever said that i was an idiot so
i'm not
let's get to digging
i knew i did something eventually if i
just kept going in the same direction
well good
good all my effort is not wasted okay so
there's gotta be diamonds around here
somewhere
i just gotta find them
what was that who
is doing that who thinks they're clever
oh where did you come from get in the
lava
die
hi where are you dumping from what is
up there
one no no i mean yay but no i i mean
also kind of no really just one
one delicious hmm ah
do not who did that where are you
oh don't tell me it was just the one
diamond in this whole area
i guess this shouldn't be too much of a
surprise but even so come on
oh man gold who needs gold it's useless
crap it's probably used for something
but i just don't know what
so i get eight gold one diamond
this is garbo okay i'm leaving this
place this was
definitely worth my time i guess i will
go ahead and get some
obsidian so that i can make another
nether portal
oh you know what i can wait
i can wait for that i don't need it now
now is not when i need it
i got one diamond that's a win it's
technically a win
it's a win in my book it's a win in
every book it's a win in everybody's
book everybody wins
i especially won this is a good
adventure i didn't get the obsidian but
i don't need it right now because the
nether is stupid and dumb and i hate it
and no one needs it
i wonder what i can do with redstone i
know you can make like rails but i don't
exactly know how
whoa do not blow up my farm
you basketball let's replace that with
something
i did not say that thank you thank you
always there for me when i need it well
this isn't nearly as many good weed as i
thought i would have at this point
i figured that being away for as long as
i was would have at least put more food
on the table than it did
but this stuff just grows slow i guess
i'll just have to beat it out with
quantity
damn so close oh hello just enough thank
you
and one more for me perfect who wants to
make
babies
you definitely do you you over there i
put down a torch for you so you have
light at night
for late night baby making however that
happens the mysterious process of which
babies are made
who knows it really truly alright is it
time for a calling of the herd
maybe not maybe not just yet i want to
get a little more numbers going up in
there
but i do have some leather and i can
have some paper
which means that i can make some more
bookshelves
these grow better than my freaking wheat
do which is the opposite of what i
experienced before
okay so we got that so we can make paper
out of that i'm not 100 sure how again
how did you make paper out of it i don't
remember why do i not remember how to
make anything
can't be because i'm stupid paper huh
piper
that's a lot of paper all right where's
book book
nice eight books hell yeah and combine
that with the books that i already have
this is gonna be a lot of bookshelf nope
that's cobblestone yep
there we go bookshelf where are you yes
boom boom baby four
beef and bookshelves four big
beefy bookshelves four bouncy
big bookshelves one two three
four yes i'm just looking to see what it
could give
that's not much better all good things
come
in time i will not rush it i will not
hurry it
my wizard's tower shall
give fruit oh fruit soon i have what i
need
for now and it is good but i can always
have
more how do i get emerald how do i get
emerald i need more farm that's what i
need
i think i can trade them bread for
emeralds and why can't i get a robot to
do this
this is tedious making the bacon
is tough hey who wants to make more
babies
hey babies oh yeah there we go now that
is what i'm talking about
there you go touch your noses together
and get it
get get it done that's a quality herd
right there
okay so here's the plant here's the rub
i've got cows i've got wheat i've got
sheep in the distance and i've got a
town that wants to trade with
every of my goods actually what do they
want hey big guy how you doing you're
cutie what are you guys doing over there
humming to yourselves hey
okay interesting wheat and carrot
i don't know how to make carrot where do
i find carrot
where would i even find carrot emerald
for gravel flint
emerald for bread interesting where do i
find carrots can i steal some carrots
from them
they wouldn't mind it's all good are
these carrots
carrots i'm stealing your carrots i'm
stealing your carrots
i'm stealing your carrots nothing you
can do what did i just get
beetroot all right sure i didn't even
know that was a thing
i think i vaguely remembered the carrots
were thing but not the beetroot soon
i'll be able to get a horsey
where am i oh my gosh
all right fine i'll make even more
farmland that's what i am i'm a farmer
in
minecraft the game about farming
farm craft all right but here's the deal
i'm doing this
so that i can build up the enchantment
energy
it's so funny that in order to slay a
dragon i gotta
raise a bunch of cows but it's all part
of the plan
pretty soon i'll be unstoppable with my
enchanted diamond
armor which i will have
eventually maybe okay i
uh but i guess i'll put carrots down and
then i guess i could start bead roots
but
in all honestly i like trying to go from
one beetroot to a whole farm's worth
it's not gonna be easy
well here we go oh nope can't plant it
well far be it for me to think that you
could just plant a beetroot
i'll eat it i can't eat it i'm not
hungry i don't know what to do with a
beetroot uh i i guess i have this now
oh beetroot seeds right of course
of course same as weed i guess all right
guys
get working get these babies up and
moving
you know what i mean oh really well two
of them will do something
it may seem insane but this is how this
works
this is how this do i'm gonna get my
enchantability
up so that i can make more cool stuff
and then i'll be able to
have better armor go kill endermen
so that i can do what i need to
do to beat the game
i know i need to go fight the ender
dragon i know that's the end of the game
theoretically and i'm gonna get there
yes
i'm gonna find another diamond if it's
the last thing i do
let's go this way now
what the hell what the hell oh lexie
didn't sound the alarms
oh baby oh baby
oh baby oh fiverr
[Applause]
thank you i am not holding that against
you okay so we got diamond that's good
there she goes i probably shouldn't
waste
diamond pickaxes i probably should be
using
iron and even if i enchant them i'm
thinking yeah
i'm thinking yeah i'm thinking yeah i'm
thinking that's what i gotta be doing
that's what i gotta do and also i
i i probably in the next episode i'm
gonna try to figure out how to do like a
redstone thing
because all i gotta do is i gotta get
the materials that i need to make a big
suit of armor enchant it up real nice
and then
do what i gotta do what do i do gold for
what is gold for
why gold why why why would i want gold
i will enchant these i don't have lapis
it's really inconvenient the way i've
set up my base
but it is okay you know what
before i do this this is what it's been
all about
i'm going to get more leather i'm going
to make more books
and then i'm going to chant the heck out
of these
iron pickaxes that i have because that's
why i've been doing this
and if i don't do it that way then i'm
an idiot
and i'm no idiot hey make more babies
before you die
make more babies make more babies more
babies more babies more babies
okay that's good all right kids you
ready to see your parents
dance yeah lixia make that family
friendly somehow
make this family friendly somehow oh i'm
hitting
the tiny ones how do i not hit
the tiny it's because it's this i use
the x
yes this is better yes this is better
yeah
uh this is horrible lixie and somebody
put on like happy uh kids game show
music or something like that
[Music]
oh oh
no no this feels bad eight leather
that's it oh god all right here we go
oh boy i'll leave two adults
ate leather i didn't get any more all
right see you around guys
okay um i have paper in here and book
i'm gonna make more book
perfect three more bookshelves that's
good that's gonna be a lot more
enchanting power
i can tell it's gonna be slightly uneven
but it's okay
doink there we go let's see what we can
do here
oh oh oh my
oh my goodness 14 no
14 14 what 14.
okay pretty cool i guess if it's in c2
yes
i i'm going for the big one i don't know
if it's any better or worse i don't know
either way that was fun i did it yeah i
did it
i'm the best okay and with that i think
that i've reached the end of this
episode here
after um fulfilling the purpose of my
farm
that was its purpose that's the only
reason i made it
feel pretty good about myself feel
pretty good so thank you everybody so
much for watching
let me know how i'm doing in the
comments below if you want to see more
you know what you have to do
you know so thanks again and as always i
will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you